[Musique]
nous savons tous aujourd'hui que
l'europe et qu'en particulier la france
sont la cible des terroristes
et donc j'ai conscience en arrivant ici
que mon premier devoir sera de tout
faire pour protéger nos concitoyens nous
travaillerons ensemble avec les services
de sécurité pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions protéger de cette menace
[Musique]
c'est une intelligence difficile c'est
une alternance exigeante elle a obligé
beaucoup de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui au
gouvernement à faire des choix
personnels difficiles
tu l'as fait je respecte profondément
ses choix personnels
je sais qu'ils sont faits dans l'intérêt
de notre pays je sais que tu seras le
développer ainsi fait le avec ce qui la
caractérise et dans ta vie une vision
sens de l'état sens du service
nous entrons dans une ère politique
nouvelle cette nouvelle ère politique
c'est une ère dans laquelle nous
acceptons de mettre de côté les
querelles politiciennes inutile dans
laquelle nous évitons de nous chamailler
sur des différences qui n'existe pas
pour que des femmes et des hommes de
bonne volonté acceptent de travailler
ensemble pour redresser le pays
[Musique]
alors ce ministère oui c'est un
ministère difficile parce qu'il faut
lutter pour réussir cette transition
énergétique et écologique
mais c'est en même temps un ministère
passionnant parce que c'est le ministère
où l'on toujours sans cesse remettre de
l'humain sur tous les sujets l'enjeu
écologique c'est la clé de voûte de la
dignité humaine et de la solidarité et
vous en avez intimement conscience c'est
un grand sujet c'est un sujet éminemment
social éminemment juste et vous avez
toujours et j'espère que je le ferai
aussi garder à l'esprit ce fait les ceux
qui aujourd'hui pendant qu'on parle sont
déjà impacté soit par la raréfaction des
ressources soit par les changements
climatiques
[Musique]
la france tient une place singulière une
place centrale dans le concert des
nations
elle a un rang à tenir
elle a une voix à faire respecter
elle a des valeurs à défendre elle a des
intérêts à défendre et j'estime qu'à cet
égard il ya une forme de continuité
entre le travail que j'ai mené au
ministère la défense et la mission qui
est la mienne aujourd'hui à la tête de
ce ministère
et c'est ma conviction et mon expérience
aussi des ministères des affaires
étrangères et de la défense ont des
destins intimement liés ne serait-ce au
cours de ces derniers mois que pour le
destin commun concernant la sécurité des
français que nous avons mené ensemble
[Musique]
sur le premier texte que vous aurez à
préparer ai-je lu celui sur la
moralisation de la vie publique
la tâche est belle mais elle est surtout
utile il vous faudra donc concilier ce
principe constitutionnel de séparation
des pouvoirs et de l'indispensable
regard extérieur sur les intérêts des
uns et des autres et vous aurez donc à
répondre à cette question jusqu'où le
retour de la confiance dans nos
institutions impôts style la défiance
vis-à-vis de ceux qui les incarnent la
loi sur la moralisation de la vie
politique va être sur la table du
conseil des ministres avant les
élections législatives
c'est l'engagement que nous avons pris
tout le monde sait ici que c'est une loi
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
qu'il y a des années que je me bats avec
l'idée que cette loi nous devrons
l'écrire et que tout est naturellement
dans cette affaire d'une importance
capitale pour que les citoyens
retrouvent un minimum de considération
et de confiance
[Musique]
c'est toujours un moment important dans
la vie d'un homme est et d'un élu bon
d'abord un sentiment de leur
reconnaissance au président de la
république et au premier ministre qui
ont décidé de me confier cette mission
et puis aussi une pensée pour tous les
agriculteurs de ce beau pays de france
pour lesquelles j'ai toujours eu
beaucoup de d'attachement je sais que la
mission est une mission difficile qu'il
y aura des moments de difficultés mais
je vais essayer avec toute ma force de
conviction de faire le maximum pour
aider le monde agricole
[Musique]